i'm mary
i'm going to talk about pistol
which is a game
i wrote in javascript
you play the pistol in this game
and i'll start off with a demo to show
you how it works
so you're the little woman on the bottom
there
and you have to kill all of these
policemen in a level
so yeah you get the idea
okay um so i wrote it in javascript
and it's based on a framework called the
render engine which is written by a man
called bret fertori
it's really cool it runs in the canvas
element
and it works in any modern web browser
but i'm not going to talk about any of
that
i'm going to talk about fakery which i
think is essential to making games
collision detection so the code that i
used to
figure out whether two objects were
colliding artificial intelligence
so the code that runs the enemies and at
the end
a little bit about falling in love uh so
fakery first up
um recently i read this book called
tinker taylor soldier spy which is by a
man called
john mccarray and
i became kind of completely obsessed
with the book i've read it several times
and it's about mi6 the british secret
service
and they discover that they've got a
russian agent
working inside the organization um and
they don't know who he is and they've
got to find him
and the name for such a person is a mole
and the way this person works is they
pretend to be
in an uh kind of helping the
organization they're a part of
but actually they're working against it
um and i think if you're a mole
um then you've got to keep like two
realities in your head
um first of all this kind of fake
reality which you're trying to convince
all the people around you that you're
working for british interests
uh to bring down the russians or
whatever um
but actually underneath is this real
reality where in fact you're trying to
feed information back to the russians or
trying to sabotage british operations
and i think making games you have to do
exactly the same thing
to keep these two realities in your head
where
there's the kind of fake reality where
you're trying to conjure these illusions
in the player's head so
you want them to believe that they're
really a grenade has just gone off by
their head or
um that they're trying to kill policemen
in some crazy
utopian world or whatever but then
underneath that you've got the real
reality which is just pixels moving
around on a screen
so you a single red pixel might
model something like a a fireball coming
out of an exploding barrel
or a piece of shrapnel from a grenade um
or a flame licking up out of a bin that
has a fire burning inside it
um and so i'm going to talk about a few
of the bits of fakery that i did
in pistol
and first up particles so a particle is
just a
name for a single pixel which has a
certain color
and a set of behaviors and i use
particles for a bunch of different
things in the game so the fireballs that
are thrown out by an exploding barrel
um the fragments of shrapnel that are
produced
by a grenade when it explodes the
shrapnel that's thrown up by a mortar
round when it hits the ground
um the flashes that come out of the
muzzle of a gun when it's fired the
sparks that are thrown out by a firework
exploding the flames that come out of a
barrel
that's on fire the debris that comes out
when
a bullet hits a wall and there's like
this shower of sparks that come out
or the drops of blood that spew out of
an enemy when they're hit with a bullet
so this is a fire done with particles
and there's four basic rules that
control each of these particles
number one they have a fixed life so
in the game in pistol slides 700
milliseconds
number two they have a fixed color cycle
so they go from yellow to red via orange
uh number three they start with a random
speed so that's how you get that
high up red particle at the top because
that had a higher
speed than average and number four
uh if your fire is burning between here
and here
then each new particle is spawned at a
random place along that line
and i use the same rules to produce
these particles
uh which for when a grenade goes off so
you can't quite see it on the slide
there but
a grenade has gone off in the bottom
right hand corner
of the screen and then it's thrown out
all these particles
but then grenade particle or rather
grenade shrapnel particles
have a bit of extra behavior which is
when they hit a solid object
then you get these plumes of yellow near
the bottom there so
pieces of shrapnel have hit the floor
and then thrown up more
more particles which are all yellow and
kind of
simulate the idea of spark a shower of
sparks
next bit of fakery in pistol is
parallax scrolling so this is a way of
faking depth
in a 2d game so if you and it's
basically just blinds sliding and
sliding over each other so
if you imagine that my two hands and my
two are two bits of
uh parallax layers then
there's three things that control when
you look at my hands
how far away they are in your brain so
number one
is this hand because it's slightly
further away looks a tiny bit smaller
number two if i move them what i promise
you is
uh equal pace past each other then this
one looks like it's moving very slightly
slower
and number three when these hands cross
each other
this one because it's nearer to you
obscures this hand
so i use those three things to
generate this illusion of depth in the
game
so you can see that in this in this
movie i've taken out all the enemies so
that lana you can't see it
so the building is really close and it's
moving faster those lanterns are further
away
and they're moving more slowly and in
these three street lamps
um they'd all be the same size if
they're all up close
but i've drawn them smaller and made
them move more slowly which makes them
look like they're further away
final bit of focus i'm going to talk
about is performance
i think pistol looks like something
on the nes so
a game from 30 years ago but you know
it's running on a modern computer
and part of the reason well there's many
reasons for this
probably i'm a terrible programmer and i
can't draw very well
but also there's not much performance
available
in the browser though webgl's looking
pretty amazing
and so i spent a lot of time optimizing
code
um however um
yeah brilliant um
i find that when you try and make code
run faster it's often a
specific thing to that piece of code
that turns out to be the problem
so i dive into lots of different bits of
code and and say okay what's wrong with
this why is it slow and then fix the
problem
but then there was a general technique
that i used again and again and was able
to apply
to lots of different pieces of code that
were trying to achieve
very different things and that was the
concept of denial
so essentially what can you ignore
um and then if you can ignore it
then it means you don't have to spend
any processing power on it and you can
use that processing power on something
else
so there's two ways to look at this if
you imagine you're an object in the game
then do you have to do your thing or can
you just not bother
so if i'm an enemy do i need to move
around
or if i'm a fire do i need to bother
burning or if i'm a firework launcher do
i need to launch
or if i'm an enemy do i need to have a
brain or can i just stand there
or if i'm a piece of ordnance like a
bullet or a piece of shrapnel do i need
to continue to exist
and the other way to look at it is if
i'm an object in the game then there's
quite often i have to look at other
objects in the game and make decisions
about them
so this most happens most often happens
with the enemies so
if i'm an enemy then and i'm trying to
avoid killing my
my buddies who are on the same side as
me do i need to
check out where they all are or can i
just look at a subset of the other
enemies in the level
or if i'm looking for a piece of cover
and i'm an enemy do i have to consider
all of the park benches in the level
or just a subset or if i'm hearing all
of these sounds of gunshots going off
around me
do i have to respond to them all or can
i ignore some of them because they are
so far away
and the way to decide on all of these
questions
is whether something's on or off camera
so if it's off camera
i probably don't have to care but if
it's on camera i do have to care
so the question is how do you decide
whether something's on or off camera
and for that we'll have to come back to
it because i need to talk about
collision detection first
so collision detection is a code that
figures out whether
one object is hitting another object
and i did a kind of two-pronged approach
to this
and first of all the first approach is
assuming that the world is a grid
which might look like this so in this
game
magic game with just black squares then
if two objects are in the same grid
square they're colliding
and if they're not in the same grid
square they're not colliding so
those two guys in the top left different
grid squares
not colliding whereas the guys in the
bottom right same grid square so they're
colliding
but the world's not a grid so we need an
extra approach
and this is called bounding boxes so in
this slide the two key objects are the
large black circles and each of them has
got a bounding box which is just
a rectangle which fits as closely as
possible around the object
and if the two bounding boxes of those
two objects are intersecting
then the two objects are colliding and
if they're not intersecting the two
objects are not colliding
so now i'm going to talk about some of
the specific
approaches to collision detection um
that i use for particular objects and
starting off with bullets
so in this slide the
black rectangles the small black
rectangles are a single bullet at
different points in time so the grenade
oh sorry the bullet starts off at
position a
moves through position b and ends up at
position c
and when the bullet's at position a then
it's not colliding with anything
whereas when it's at position c then
it's colliding with that large white
rectangle
so we can just use bounding boxes here
to figure out that it's colliding at
position c
and we would be done because when a
bullet hits something it's just removed
from the game
but there's a bit of extra stuff because
actually it's
when a bullet hits something it's not
just removed from the game there's also
a shower of sparks that come out of the
object it hit
so we need to find position b because
that's where the shower of sparks is
going to come from
and so the thing about writing a game is
that
you don't actually see your objects move
through every
pixel on their path from a to c so
i see uh or rather the game engine sees
the bullet at position a
and then it next sees it at position c
and it's passed through position b
but it we didn't see it so you need to
figure out where position b
is and the way you do this is you draw a
line between position a and position c
and then you take the four lines that
define the edges of the large white
rectangle
and you say okay which of those lines is
the
line a to c intersecting with oh it's
the left hand side
so you know which two lines are
intersecting and then you can find the
intersection point
and you're done
grenades so grenades are a little bit
different
because when they hit an object they
don't just disappear they bounce
so for this we'll need position b but we
already know how to do that
um but we also need to find out the new
trajectory that the grenade's going to
go on after it hits the large white
rectangle
so it's the same thing again it's
started off at position a
and it ends up at position c we find
position b to figure out where to bounce
it from
and then we just need to find that gray
line that's sort of pointing
diagonally down in that direction and
the way you do this
is that you know which side it hits so
it's that left hand side
and so you just reflect the bullet sorry
the grenade vector
in the side that it hit so this is my
side this is the vector i reflect it
like that
and then i'm done but there's an extra
bit of complication with grenades
excuse me because grenades have an area
where
so when you draw that line a to c if
you've got a bullet
you just draw it from the single pixel
at position a to the single pixel at
position c
but with a grenade you need to figure
out where to draw that line from so
let's say we pick the top left-hand
corner of where the grenade is so
i draw a line from the top left-hand
corner of position a
to the top left-hand corner of position
c and that gives me line one
but we're a bit because line
one's not actually intersecting with a
large white rectangle
okay no big deal we'll just draw that
line from the bottom right hand corner
right
so draw the line from the
bottom right hand corner of position a
to the bottom right hand corner of
position c
gives us line two that line's
intersecting we're done
but what about this so the grenades
approaching from a different angle in
this scenario
and we draw that same line bottom right
right hand corner of position a
to bottom right hand corner of position
c that gives us line one
oh no it's totally not intersecting
again
so need a bit of a rethink and
so you need to use a different strategy
for grenades and this is called sweeping
according to the internet
um so it's the same scenario grenade
starts out at position a
ends up at position c which is where we
detect the collision
and then to find out where the grenade
actually entered the object and
therefore find out where position b
is where we need to bounce the grenade
from then you just
take the grenade when it's at position c
and move it back along its trajectory
to position d but we need to keep going
because there's still no intersection
with a side
so then we keep going we move the
grenade from position d
back along to position e now we've got
the intersection
now we've got position b we know it
about so grenade from we're done
ace so with all of this in mind then we
can now figure out whether something's
on or off camera
and the strategy is bounding boxes so
all of the objects in the game
have a bounding box and the view the
camera
is just a single large bounding box
somewhere in the world
and so we can just say okay
bin is your bounding box um intersecting
with the views bounding box if it is
then you're on camera if it's not you're
off camera
but we run into a performance problem
here again because
this check of a bounding box against
another boundary box to see whether
they're intersecting
is not slow but it's not fast either so
we need to make it faster
for moving objects there's not a lot you
can do apart from just try and write
code efficiently
but with unmoving objects then it's
quite easy because
their bounding boxes don't change so
this means when you load the level
then all of the unmoving objects like
bins or park benches or the floor
or the fences at the both ends of the
level
um their bounding boxes are not going to
change throughout the entire game
so when the level loads you just say to
each object
right totally generate your bounding box
and then store it so this means when you
do that check
of the view bounding box against an
object's bounding box it doesn't have to
generate its bounding box it can just go
and fetch it from memory
so that's a performance improvement but
you can actually take it a bit further
because
the answer to whether a particular
unmoving object is on or off camera
doesn't change all the time so if the
camera hasn't moved
the answer's still the same so i let's
imagine some
scenario where i say uh bin are you on
camera and he
fetches his bounding box which he's got
pre-stored
and then he compares it against the
bounding box of the camera
and then comes back the answer and says
uh yes i'm on camera
and then i come back two seconds later
and the camera hasn't moved in that time
um and so i say uh ben i need to ask you
again are you on camera and he says
like dude you totally just asked me that
um
i've already stored the result to your
last request so i'm just going to give
you the answer from that cache
and then you don't need to you only need
to clear the cache when the camera moves
which only happens when the pistol slap
moves
which is relatively speaking not that
often so this means that
you can check whether objects are on off
camera um
extremely cheaply performance wise and
that was a big
big win so pronouncement topic
artificial intelligence so this is the
code that runs the enemies
and the technique i used is called
behavior trees
and a behavior tree is just a special
type of state machine
except it's in a tree structure
obviously
and so because it's a state machine then
that means the objects that it controls
have states
so one of the states that a enemy and
pistol can be in is fighting
and another state you can be in is
shooting but these states are slightly
different from each other because
fighting
is like it's you're not actually the
enemies when they are
in the fight state they're not actually
doing anything it's more like a gateway
to a set of states where they'll
actually achieve some
useful function whereas fighting oh
sorry shooting is actually doing
something
so when a enemy is in the shoot state
it's actually firing actual bullets with
an actual gun
so in this diagram of a totally generic
behavior tree then
fighting would be the fork point so
in the middle there and shooting would
be an example of a leaf node
so the general rule is if you're at a
fork point you're deciding what to do
next
whereas if you're at a leaf node then
you're actually deciding to achieve
something and
do some sort of action in the game like
shooting a bullet
now there's two way there's two rules
that govern
movement around the behavior tree and
the first one is can i do this so
before moving to a state then the code
always asks am i allowed to do this so
it might say am i allowed to fight and
the code comes back and says
yeah there's totally an enemy there and
he's got guns so you should totally
fight him
um or with shooting can i shoot
um yeah you've totally got bullets
you've got a gun
do it and then the other thing that
governs movement around the behavior
tree
is a strategy and this is a method for
choosing
where you're going to move next in the
tree
so in this we're in the fight state and
we need a strategy for choosing whether
to try and shoot or try and throw a
grenade
and the two strategies are used in
pistol there are a bunch of others
that you can use in behavior trees but
this was enough for pistol the
first strategy i used was prioritization
and in this then
you just start at the left and you
run the first sub-branch that you can
run
so i'm in the fight state and i say okay
start at left can i shoot
the answer comes back no um so i say all
right then can i throw a grenade
the answer comes back yes so i move to
the throw grenade state
i throw a grenade and then i move back
up to the parent state
so that's prioritization so you choose
the first one
that can run and then you go back to the
parent
the other strategy is sequentialization
which is where you run
every sub-branch that you can so you
might end up running all of the
sub-branches or none or some
so i'm in the fight state the strategy
is sequentialization
i say can i shoot and the answer comes
back yes so i move to the shoot state
i shoot and then i move straight on to
the throw grenade station can i
and say can i throw a grenade the answer
comes back yeah you can totally throw a
grenade
so i throw a grenade and then move back
to the fight state
so with all that in mind here is the
only slide with any code on it
um it's json so it's not even real code
but it's pretty much all of the code
that
all of the behavior tree for pistol
and we're going to go through it so
i'm on line one i'm in the idle state
the strategy of the idle state is
prioritized
so this means i need to find the first
child that can run
and then run it but actually the idle
state only has one child
and that's line three fight um
so i say can i fight and the code comes
back and says
yeah there's totally an enemy there you
can fight so i moved to
to the fight state the strategy again is
prioritized
so now i've got three children to choose
from so i
check out the first one on line five
find cover so i say can i find cover
and the code comes back and says yeah
there's
there's a bin between you and the enemy
you can run
and hide behind that so i move to the
fine cover state
and the strategy of the fine cover state
on line five
is sequentialization so this means i'm
going to run all the children that apply
and then move back up so i go to line
seven and say can i turn towards the
player
and the code comes back and says yep
you're turned away from him
so uh you should totally turn towards
him so i moved to the turn towards
player state
turned towards the player and then i
move right on to line eight and say can
i stand and the code says yeah you can
stand because you're crouched at the
moment
so i move to the stand state and then i
stand up and then i move to line nine
and i say can i run for cover which just
comes back yes
and so i run for cover and then i move
to line 10
and i say can i shoot and again you got
bullets you've got guns you can totally
shoot
so i move to the shoot state and then i
and then i go back up to the fine cover
state now i'm probably not
in cover still so the answer on line
five
can i find cover will come back yes you
can
so i'm going to keep on looping through
this fine cover state
until i get to cover and let's say i
actually make it there and i don't get
killed on the way
then eventually i'll come back up to
line five and say can i find cover
and the answer comes back no you can't
because you're already in cover you're
already ducked down behind that bin
so now i say okay back up to the fight
state line three
and then i say i'm in this i'm using the
prioritized strategy
so i check out find cover again still
can't find cover because i'm still
ducked down behind that bin
and so i go to line 13 to throw grenade
state and i say can i throw a grenade
and it said the code comes back and says
yeah you've got grenades throw one
so i throw one and then back up to the
fight state again line three
now it's going to be find cover can't do
that because it's still in cover
throw a grenade can't do that anymore
because you've just thrown one and so
then you move to line 14
can i shoot and you shoot so
that's basically how the ai and pistol
start works there's a bit of extra stuff
but it's not that instructive
now why is this cool um
i think number one with that behavior
tree
then you can move around that json
really really easily
so you can change the behavior of the ai
with minimal code uh changes um so
obviously there's a bunch of code which
does inferences about
where the bins are and and whether
you've got any bullets and all of that
stuff but that's all nicely tucked away
inside you know modularized and it's
it's it's it's kind of
um not dependent on other bits of code
and second of all i think
that you can actually read that json and
understand it so i showed this json to
my mum
when i was trying to talk about uh
pistols and what i've been working on
in my spare time and i think she totally
got it
i think um and so i think this means you
can collaborate on ai with
non-programmers and i think it's always
good to be able to do that
so penultimate topic before i talk about
falling in love
um i want to talk about discovery
um when i wrote pistol site was the
first game i've written
and it was the first major javascript
project i'd done and i'd never done any
i hadn't done much ai work and hadn't
done anything to do with collision
detection as far as i can remember
and i didn't really read up that much in
advance
and probably if it had been something i
was doing for work i would have felt
obliged to do that and so i would have
done but
because it was for fun then
i kind of just want didn't want to spoil
a surprise and so
i figured out that grenade sweeping
stuff and um
figured out you know why my uh
enemies were running around madly
shooting each other and
um didn't google much and didn't read
any books
um in advance just because that process
of discovering
how to do something even when you know
someone else has already solved this
problem
i think is like one of the most joyous
feelings in the whole world
and so that's why i didn't want to spoil
a surprise
so i suppose what i'm saying is don't
read any books and don't learn anything
except by doing and so the final topic
is falling in love
and this is not really about code that
much
so apologies
one evening maybe a few months ago
i was in my kitchen writing some code
with pistol slap
and i had this ticket to go and see this
band called wolf parade who are really
really good
and and they were playing down the road
for me
where i live in berlin um and i was
really into the code and i really wanted
to stay and write it but then
i sort of forced my tore myself away and
then
dashed down the road went to this gig
and then after that i ended up going out
with some friends and
and and and and and drinking quite a lot
and stuff and
then i came home at sort of seven or
eight in the morning
um as it's kind of still drunk basically
um and sat down and carried on picked up
where i'd left off with the code um
and i'm in a band um
as a sort of separate thing um and so
when i write songs then more and more
often recently then i've started to
write about my real life rather than
about more generic things
um and so i wrote a song about the fact
that i'd been
writing the code for pistol slide in my
kitchen and then run out to see wolf
parade and then
got drunk on gimlets with my friends and
and and and gone some clubs and stuff
and
um then when when i figured out grenade
sweeping then i was
in a bar called for being a really nice
bar in berlin
um drinking hemingway so whenever i
think about the grenade sweeping code
i think about the taste of hemingway's
which is a it's a really nice cocktail
by the way it's got
grapefruit juice and some sort of red
thing and gin
um and uh um
so i sort of felt like pistols like was
becoming entwined with my life
and then um some of the bits of graffiti
in the level
i i it is level singular at the moment
um in the level in pistol
are from my diary or things that i'd
seen around berlin
um and then recently i found myself at a
party
talking about pistols like to a stranger
who was a non-programmer
and he seemed to sort of find it
interesting i hope um
and so i suppose what i'm trying to say
is that pistols have become
more and more entwined my life or more
like what more importantly programming
has been
come entwined with my life and i think
falling in love like with a person
is so thrilling because
um they show you these possibilities
that you'd never even realized existed
so they show you new ways of thinking
about things or or
or new perspectives and so it sets off
all of these endorphins in your brain
that are just
super exciting um and so i felt like the
same thing happened
with pistol in the sense that it
had become entwined with my life and
and different parts of my life had
started to inform each other
because of it so you know the songs i
was writing and the code i was writing
and
the friendships i was having and the
bars i was going to and
and the graffiti i was seeing all kind
of became entwined
and so i suppose in summary what i mean
is that pistol made me fall in love
with programming
thanks
uh any questions my name or pistol
name
what's the story of the name oh okay um
basically it was a joke um uh
i started writing the code last summer
um
and i was thinking about the most
ridiculous name that i could have and
i thought well surely i've got to
combine sex and violence into a single
phrase
um and then i thought okay yeah pistol's
up brilliant
and so then i when i was talking about
the fact that i was writing this game to
my friends
they said what's it going to be called
and i said as a joke pistol
and then i tried to change it later but
they were all like no no no no that's
the best thing about it
um so it's stuck um so you can play it
at pistolslap.com
if you want to anyone else
how did you choose the name sylvester
for your javascript
so file say that again i was going
through your code how was uh how did you
choose the name sylvester for your main
javascript file uh actually that's not
mine that's
made by a man called james coughlin
who's an excellent javascript developer
um it's a library for doing
mathematical calculations based on
vectors
um i don't know how he chose it so you'd
have to ask him
but he blogs at jcoglund.com he's a
super genius he should totally check out
his code
did you look at box2d for your uh your
physics framework
so um i found out about box2d at the
berlin javascript group quite recently
and i was like god dammit all of those
knights crying into my gimlet
about you know the fact that my
grenades were still bouncing into bins
and not
on them um uh so i i nearly killed
myself at that point
but then i thought it's fine i'll just
totally integrate it
so i spent a very difficult week
integrating box 2d with the game
but found out that actually there were
some things that
because i'd written them specifically
for my game were better in my collision
detection code
but this is not to say that box 2d sucks
because it's awesome obviously
but it solves a much greater more
general class of problems
and so i found that i wanted specific
behavior for different objects and so i
found i kept my code in the end
but box 2d is totally great so if
anyone's writing a game use that not my
collision detection code because it
sucks
anyone else
nope okay thanks
did you remember the baby oh no